The United States spends about $50 billion
a year on foreign aid.
That sounds like a lot, doesn’t it?
So it’s not surprising that Americans ask
why their government sends so much money abroad
when there are pressing needs at home.
But is aid simply charity?
Or does it serve U.S. interests?
Foreign aid has long been a vital part of
U.S. foreign policy.
It takes on hunger and it improves health.
It builds schools, creates jobs, it trains
law enforcement.
It encourages other countries to support our
goals.
And it has traditionally enjoyed bipartisan
support in Washington.
That is until recently.
Many now question its purpose and its expense
for Americans.
Let’s go back to those numbers.
$50 billion dollars is a lot of money.
But it’s actually just 1 percent of the
total federal budget.
By comparison, defense spending is over $700
billion dollars.
That’s 17% of the federal budget.
In sheer dollar terms, the U.S. is the world’s
largest aid donor.
But the U.S. is also the world's largest
economy.
Many countries give a lot more than the U.S.
as a percentage of their economies.
Now let’s see where that money goes.
Some of the biggest outlays go to fighting
disease.
U.S. aid has been a gamechanger in the fight
against HIV and AIDS around the world.
Its investment of over $90 billion dollars
is credited with saving millions of lives
and preventing the disease from spreading
further.
The United States also spends a lot to help when natural disasters strike or when wars force people to flee their homes.
U.S. foreign aid supports international organizations
like the UN Development Program or World Bank.
They work on everything from reducing infant
deaths to building highways and ports in poorer countries.
And the United States funds programs to promote
free-markets and democracy abroad.
But here’s something you might not realize.
Military and security aid is also part of
that $50 billion dollars.
Much of this money goes to help allies with
equipment and training.
Iraq, Afghanistan, Israel, Egypt, and Jordan
receive the most support.
So, is foreign aid expensive?
Sure.
But it’s also an investment.
That $50 billion dollars nurtures alliances.
It promotes democracy, trade, and economic growth.
It helps prevent conflicts that might lead
to military intervention.
It can even fight terrorism.
As the Joint Chiefs of the U.S. Military have argued, “diplomacy and development are a hell of a lot cheaper than defense.”
As an investment, foreign aid is quite cost-effective.
But providing international aid isn’t just
about the costs.
It's vital for a global leader.
If that still is a role the United States
wants to play.